sadly we live in a world with the likes
of the brilliant Mario 3d World and
pikmin 3 aren't enough for people to go
out and buy wii u but maybe they just
need another form of encouragement how
does a wii u mario kart 8 bundle sound
nintendo looks set to unveil a new mario
kart wii u console bundle with artwork
for the deal popping up online friend
site game blog reports that the console
is due to arrive when the game launches
across the US and Europe on May
thirtieth the box is reported to contain
a standard black wii u premium that's
the one with 32 gigabytes of storage a
copy of the game and a one-week trial of
Nintendo's Wii U karaoke app Nintendo
has not officially confirmed the bundle
but its existence likely won't come as a
surprise the company is no stranger to
these sorts of bundles having released a
similar deal for last year's the legend
of zelda the windwaker HD that bundle
was released at the same three hundred
dollar price as a standard we you
suggesting a sizable discount could be
in store for anyone currently mulling
over whether to invest in a Wii U for
the next Mario Kart game earlier this
month it was revealed that Mario Kart 8
will feature 32 courses with half of
them entirely new is mario kart 8 enough
to convince you to pick up a Wii U where
are you going to let Nintendo's little
box that could get blue shelled into
oblivion let us know in the comments and
I'll see you next time